- Des affiches comme celle-ci,
il y en a de plus en plus
aux abords de l'autoroute 117.
Signe d'une réalité de plus
en plus difficile pour
les employeurs.
Au centre de villégiature
de Mont-Tremblant, le manque
de personnel est flagrant.
DANIEL BILIÉ, Directeur général
Tourisme Mont-Tremblant
- Seulement en juillet,
on estimait qu'environ
400 postes étaient toujours
disponibles, qu'on a pas réussi
à combler, ça représente tout
près de 140 000 heures
de travail qui n'ont pas
été comblées.
- Ça, c'est du jamais vu?
- C'est du jamais vu.
CRISTIANE ROMERO, dg,
Asso. villégiature de Tremblant
- La pénurie de main d'oeuvre
ne s'est pas déclarée
pendant la pandémie, elle
s'est accentuée.
Pas plus tard que ce matin, je
parlais avec des gens d'un
commerce, je suis allée
me chercher mon petit café,
puis je dis : "Comment ça va?"
On me rapportait encore :
"On est sur les genoux".
On a eu quand même
des données record cet été, au
niveau de nos commerçants, au
niveau de nos hôteliers, mais il
n'en demeure pas moins qu'on n'a
pas assez de personnel
pour faire le travail.
- Résultat : la majorité
des commerces doivent fermer
une, deux parfois 3 journées
par semaine.
PASCALE NANTAIS, co-propriétaire
La Pizzateria
- On a perdu des centaines,
et des centaines de milliers
de dollars.
- Donc pour deux personnes?
- Ça fait 25 ans que
Pascale Nantais travaille
en restauration.
Pour la première fois,
elle doit assumer différents
rôle sur le plancher.
- On est loin de l'époque où
justement on avait des piles de
cv et qu'on avait l'embarras
du choix.
On en engage un, puis
tu ne sais pas s'il
va rentrer le lendemain.
Maintenant c'est quasiment
malsain, le climat, tu as tout
le temps peur de te faire
voler tes cuisiniers.
- Salaire augmenté, assurances
bonifiées, mais cela
ne suffit pas.
Autre défi : l'hébergement.
Le marché immobilier
de Mont-Tremblant est
majoritairement locatif
et réservé aux touristes.
Il existe peu de logements
de disponibles, et
surtout abordables.
- On aurait pu trouver
des employés qui étaient
intéressés à venir travailler
chez nous. Ces gens-là ont
cherché de l'hébergement à
proximité, et ça n'a pas
été possible.
Devant cette problématique,
Pascale a décidé d'acheter
une maison de 6 chambres,
pour loger ses futurs employés.
- On espère que ce soit un plus
à trouver du personnel qui
provient de l'extérieur.
RAFFAELE FREDDI, Promoteur
immobilier
- On va conserver ces arbres
ici qui vont faire partie
du campus.
- Autre solution, construire
des logements abordables.
- On est juste à peine
8-9 minutes de la station.
- Ce promoteur immobilier
construira 120 unités.
La première phase du campus
Ryan, un projet de
40 millions $, sera complété
en décembre 2022. L'objectif est
d'offrir des appartements à
des prix raisonnables.
- J'ai jamais vu un projet
avancer si rapidement
que celui-ci.
Les travaux ne sont même pas
encore commencés que
l'engouement se fait sentir.
- Ça fait juste deux semaines
qu'on a commencé la liste
d'attente, on a au dessus
de 100 personnes qui se sont
inscrites.
La plupart des gens qui ont
réservé à date qui sont
des employeurs de la région.
PAUL CALCE, dg, corporation
de développement économique
- Là, ce qui est un modèle,
c'est qu'il y a des projets
privés qui se dessinent.
Il y a , ce qu'on travaille avec
les villes, c'est un partenariat
avec les entreprises aussi.
Parce que les entreprises ont
une responsabilité importante
aussi là-dedans. C'est ben beau
d'investir dans le recrutement,
l'attraction de
la main-d'oeuvre, mais si
t'es pas capable de les loger
aujourd'hui, tes efforts,
ça donnera rien.
- La solution passe peut-être
par redéfinir les modèles
de développements économiques,
croit Paul Calce.
- Le secteur de l'habitation,
le transport, les écoles,
la santé, ça fait partie
du développement économique,
donc, ça les municipalités sont
conscientes de ça et ils veulent
participer, mais pas à n'importe
quel prix parce qu'il y a
le citoyen en arrière. Fait que
le citoyen il dit : "Moi là,
je paye des taxes assez
importantes. Mais l'employeur
lui, il fait quoi?" Donc c'est
ça le modèle qu'on est en train
de travailler actuellement.
- Ce qu'on a peur ici
présentement, c'est l'étalement
urbain, étant donné qu'il n'y a
pas de logements abordables,
on incite les gens à aller
s'installer justement encore
plus en périphérie, donc on veut
éviter ça à tout prix.
- Pénurie de la main-d'oeuvre,
pénurie de logements abordables,
et relance économique. Les défis
seront nombreux pour
les prochains élus municipaux.
Ici Marie-Michelle Lauzon,
Radio-Canada, Mont-Trembl